in the lobby of Ramsay Solutions Kevin
is with us hey Kevin how are ya
I'm better than I deserve Dave how are
you welcome man good to have you I'm the
same better than I deserve where do you
live
other than Orange County California I'm
a Los Angeles area welcome to Nashville
so you're all the way across the United
States to be here in person to do your
debt free scream yes awesome
well we're honored to have you sir how
much have you paid off about 35,000 very
cool and how long did that take you
about a few years most of it was done in
this year
very good very fast then and what kind
of income were you making during those
two years um I started up at 60 and then
did a lot of consulting work and a guy
new job got it up to around 100 thousand
more to go dude you've been busting it
yeah burning the oil good for you so
what kind of debt was the thirty five
thousand but plenty of it was student
loans and about you know the rest of
those it was a clarify in 2014 uh what
kind of car that's a Honda Civic good
deal then so you pay it off or sell it I
paid it off good good fine good for you
this is great so tell me your story what
happened two years ago that put you on
to this journey well I was listening to
a podcast no I caught your show on the
radio and you're ranting and yelling at
people and I thought that was a I
thought you're just really entertaining
and um I I listened to you but I wasn't
really taking it seriously until the end
of last year I mean I looked at my bank
account on it was I I looked at it I was
like man I really just wasted this whole
year I didn't do anything and then I'm a
pretty competitive guy so um a guy um I
was on the show he's about 26
you paid off more debt than I had I was
like oh this if this guy can do it then
I should you there you go that's it so
now somebody's listening to you thinking
the same thing yeah how old are you
110th I have 25 years old and you paid
off $35,000 in two years very fun so
what do you tell people the secret to
getting out of debt is good man you did
it just the state discipline the I think
the first thing that's the most
important is to create a budget and
follow it and because at least that way
you're able to see where your money's
going because um yeah when I started
creating a budget I started to realize I
was spending too much money on food um
sometimes I was going a little bit
overboard on
so when I created the budget I was able
to see where everything was going and
yeah you know you're single I take it
yeah I made you're not married okay and
so the way the way you were using your
pronouns I assumed okay and so you know
you need something like a budget the
budget hold you accountable to you
doesn't it yes it's like I said I was
gonna do this now I didn't do it and
there's nobody mad at you but you then
but you've got a game plan and it gives
you the guardrails to stay inside the
road and keep it running so that's
that's very good insight so what was the
hardest part of this process for you I
would say just delay gratification I
there's a lot of things I would I wanted
to buy for myself and I told myself like
if I didn't go over my entertainment
budget then I'll use whatever money is
left over to go towards the things I
want to buy I and it was hard because I
knew I could buy them but they weren't
in the budget so I wouldn't let myself
have it so you know just go month after
month it's not having like these little
things that I want it for myself
and that's pretty difficult it's a
pretty simple formula but it's painful
yeah yeah it just hurt you know I could
buy it and I'm working but was it worth
it it was definitely worth it how's it
feel now you don't have any penny much I
feels great I mean it's just happening
last month so I'm still getting used to
it I chose trying to you know do baby
step three come but it feels great very
cool well good for you man very good
this is excellent and and so when you
look back on this from when you started
it was it easier or harder than you
thought it was going to be when you
started I think it was harder because
what I did was I created you know I'm a
big math guy I had an excel sheet that
had like you know my whole life planned
out and the debt-free part was you know
a small part of the spreadsheet but
everyone thought she's like I've only
done one line of that spreadsheet and
it's I still have a long way to go so
that was pretty hard you know I did a
lot of consulting work as I said I
actually was listening to the segment
you did earlier in the show about the
guy who was you know working like a lot
of hours yeah home just inside and you
know it's a little offended by all the
comments that you're talking about that
people are leaving on the thing like you
know they're making fun of them but you
know I was just thinking what you always
say is still super normal I'm gonna be
normal
yeah if broke people are making fun of
your financial plan you're right on
track right yeah
exactly what do you do for a living I'm
a software engineer uh-huh very cool
well we're honored to have you Kevin
congratulations very well done Kevin
from Orange County Los Angeles market
$35,000 paid off at 25 years old did it
in two years making 60 till he started
working extra now he's making a hundred
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream three two one
I'm debt free well done love it love it
love it that is fabulous
you guys would be so rich so fast and be
able to do so much not only for
yourselves and for your family but for
others